for this to the computer.
OK, so back to the question about melatonin.
So melatonin can be used as a sleep aid
because what melatonin does is help you fall asleep.
It doesn't help you stay asleep, but it does help you fall asleep.
So if you're not able to fall asleep,
then you can use melatonin to help you fall asleep.
But it's, oh, I fall asleep really well,
but I wake up two hours later, and I can't get back to sleep.
Then melatonin really is at your solution for sleep.
You need to use some malaria in room.
You need to look at glutamate levels.
You need to look at what's waking you up if it's pain.
You need to look at possible adrenal dysfunction.
That can wake you up in the middle of the night.
There are some other things too that we want to address.
But then the second part of the question
is can you use melatonin as a cancer killer?
That's only with high dose melatonin.
So you'd be using it to, I typically start people
with 20 milligrams before bed,
and then you bump up to 40 and then to 60 milligrams before bed.
That's the typical dosage for melatonin to use it.
It's not a cancer killer in itself,
but it could aid the uptake of everything else
you're doing into the cells sometimes.
I know some doctors recommended it with all their cancer patients.
We don't recommend it with all our cancer patients.
We test people on it, but it's certainly something you could add.
And it will help with sleep.
So there isn't really any known side effects of high dose melatonin.
Typically, people get used to it,
and then once you're taking that high dose,
it ends up working as far as sleep help
goes similar to if you just took low dose.
But the high dose melatonin we have in our store two,
that's the highest dose that we have found
comes in a 20 milligram capsule.
But if someone is just trying to use melatonin to go to sleep,
then you would use a smaller dose.
And what we use is a product called insomnetal
because it has melatonin and malaria in root
and some other things to help call me to the root
and to make levels that just relax you
and help you fall asleep that way too.
It seems like 20 grams or higher would put someone in a coma
because wow.
Yeah, it really doesn't matter.
It doesn't make you more sleepy
because as far as how melatonin works on your braid,
you have a kind of a limit on what you need and what you'll use.
So if a person was using melatonin just to go to sleep,
20 milligrams would just be a wasted dose.
So you typically start with three milligrams
and maybe up to six or nine,
but typically people just for sleep purposes
don't need any more of that.
And if they took more, it wouldn't help them anymore.
Well, I put a picture of Disney World there.
You can see that, right?
Because we just got back from Disney World.
Oh, well, just got back quite a while ago.
And somebody asked me, you know, about Disney World,
we go down to Disney World a lot
because our kids were little.
That was a good place to get them lost
and we could fight them at the end of the day.
Just kidding.
We just got back and it is magical.
And if you've been there, you know what I mean.
And again, we've been there a lot.
When our kids were younger, we drive under that magical arch
on the way and the kids would scream
like they're entering the land of milk and honey.
So it was kind of fun.
All the kids would scream, yay, we're a Disney World.
And it was very magical.
They even have magic bands that you wear at Disney World.
If you haven't been there lately,
that's kind of a doer thing the last couple of years.
They're the keys to your room.
They're your tickets to the park
and you never need to carry cash or credit card.
It's just magic.
You buy something at the gift shop.
And yes, they do have gift shops in Disney World
just so in case you didn't know.
And I remember the first time we came out
when I bought by a first set of Mickey ears.
To follow up by Walla, they said,
no, sir, you just need to use your magic band.
So it happened to magic band down there and Walla,
it was just magic.
Do the kids get a magic band?
Yes, that could be the dangerous part
because the kids,
and it's just magic.
But they, I tell you,
what was it magical was Disney figured out
that they must have put like a tracker
of that little magic band.
So once you cross back out through the magical arch
and left the land of milk and honey,
a dig your credit card gets melted right there
in your pocket just melts all over your leg.
No, plastic goose, seared.
They know what they're doing.
Few layers of epithelium out by right thigh.
It was just magical.
So yeah, somebody asked,
well, what's it like going to Disney at Christmas time?
Isn't it really crowded there?
And I said, well, you want to practice.
If you're going to go to Disney at Christmas time,
practice, start by just going home
and fill your livid room just deep with mashed potatoes.
And then pick a spot on each side of the wall
and wade back and forth across your room
through the mashed potatoes.
And that's what it's like going to Disney world
at Christmas time.
Like China, like that.
And actually, if you find yourself,
if you find yourself that it's pretty easy to breathe,
and you can see where you're going,
then you don't have enough mashed potatoes.
That's what it's like going to Disney world.
So why we like going to Disney world,
I still have it figured that out.
So genetic deep fact I have that leads to insanity.
All right, that's about Disney world.
I don't have any other slides, but this,
but so we'll look at this while we open up
for more questions.
Hi, Dr. Conard.
This is Talma, can everybody hear me?
Yes, Talma, go ahead.
Okay, cool.
All right, so this is the first time I joined Zoom,
I wasn't able to get on the right schedule.
So I'm happy to be here.
I'm happy to be here.
Why don't work for you this time.
Um, so two things happened.
Yesterday I had my mercury,
one quadrant of my mercury fillings taken out.
And at the same time,
Dr. took a cat scan of that area and tells me
I have some more work and cat and cat salation
or whatever that has to be cleaned out.
So and then today I just came back from stress,
a magnesium stress test for my heart.
And so I feel like I need to detox.
And I don't know what to use.
Okay, so let's talk about that.
So when a person has their mercury fillings removed,
even by a biological dentist,
who's doing it right,
with the mercury vacuum and rubber dam and cannula,
all other things that they will use to protect you
from exposure to those mercury vapors
that they're drilling out of your body,
you do want to then use a key later afterwards.
So a key later will help grab onto any mercury
that is spilled into your body
because you're going to spill some.
And you know, if they're giving you a sedative,
of some kind, even if it's no vacate,
you want to detox that too.
So we typically tell people to use the product keylex,
but we can't, keylex is a product by zymogen,
and remember I talked to you about the zymogen products
that we had to private label them
because they don't want them sold online anywhere.
So our the private label name is keylet clear.
And that is just a key later.
So a key later is a nutritional substance
that grabs onto toxins that helps pull them onto the body.
The other thing a person could use
is helping with liver detoxification,
which is go back to our first question,
which was, you know, if I have some acid by liver area,
how do I help detox the liver?
Well, that's where you could use coffee enemas.
That's where you could use castor oil packs over the liver.
That's where you could use milk, thistle,
pun-1 assist, which is a product that helps assist
that pun-1 pathway.
The pun-1 pathway is specific for how you detox
many heavy metals.
Curcumin can be a good benefit also
for helping liver detoxification.
There's some other herbs that I could think of
if I spent a little more time on that,
but definitely using a key later
and helping with liver detoxification,
primary, what is coffee enemas?
Okay, so I'm on the key legs one twice a day,
should I just double that?
No, I would just stay on that.
That's plenty of dose for that.
Okay, and I did the castor oil and the iron cleanse last night.
Good, good.
So the iron cleanse that I forgot to mention that,
also helping with other detox portals like sodas
and things like that would be helpful too.
And how often should I be doing,
I do the milk crystal already.
I think I'm on pun-1.
And compare definitely curcumin.
So you might be covered just fine.
Okay. How often do you could do the foot bath?
You could do that every day.
Okay.
All right, thanks.
Yep, and if you do have a salto, you could do that every day too.
Okay.
All right.
Next question.
Dr. Connor.
Huh?
Mrs. Donna.
Hi, Donna.
Hi.
Apparently you every day.
Oh, thank you very much.
I have several questions.
Today, one is my calcium went really high.
This blood blood draw that I had.
Could that be from food intake?
Anything that has a calcium like cheese, milk,
you know, set or fit or anything that has calcium in it.
Could that be keeping it high?
Or is it because it's taking it out of my bone?
Most likely it's taking it out of your bone.
You know, most, you know, if person does not have any sort of cancer
and they, you know, go eat a whole bunch of calcium
and take a whole bunch of calcium supplements,
they still won't have high blood calcium.
So calcium levels are regulated by your kidney.
They're regulated by your parathyroid hormone.
And they're, so blood calcium levels from dietary sources
won't push your calcium levels high.
So when you, when a person has high calcium levels,
you think of, if they don't have a history of cancer,
you think of parathyroid disease.
And if they do have cancer, you think of bone loss.
So then we go to how are we going to keep that calcium in the bone
and keep decreased destruction.
There's not a lot of data out there on that.
The only data that I found is EGCG from grade T extract will help that
because what's going on at the site of the cancer in the bone
is a, what's called an osteolytic reaction.
The bone is really broken down.
And that is what goes on at that time.
That to get too specific, but there's a specific cytokine
immune chemical called imedoglobulin per IL-6
is a cytokine and IL-6 levels can be lowered
really only by grade T extract.
So I think, don't you, aren't you already on EGCG?
No, I'm not.
Is it, are you on TVGO?
No.
Okay, we really should, who we should add that to your protocol then.
So we used to use our clear EGCG,
but the, the more studies I've done on the source of grade T extract,
it's so, so important because one study I saw
is that every source that they found was, was tainted.
Grade T happens to be something that picks up toxins
from the soil and the environment more readily
than just about any herb that's grown.
And virtually all the grade T sold in America is from China.
And the only company that I currently trust
that sources their grade T for their EGCG,
grade T extract and is completely crazy anal about testing it
and the purification of it is US enzymes.
So US enzymes, TVGO, which is a newer product
that they started with is the best source
and the most readily available.
So I would take that and I would do probably
three a day to start with.
Okay.
Yeah, because it jumped to 11.9.
Yeah, we got to drop that down.
You got to really make sure also that you're just gulping water
so you're flushing your kiddies out.
Right, well I do that because I've had kidney stones
that had to be removed.
Yeah.
The next question I had is lost the weight.
I've lost quite a bit of weight and I can't afford
to lose any more weight.
I was just wondering is it because my food
and the nutrients are not being properly absorbed
into the body?
Kid B, that's part of it.
Did you have, have you watched that video of the caccia?
Yes.
So yeah, part of it is that.
So if a person has got issues
and they're not absorbing their food very well,
their nutrients very well,
then they're not going to be getting the value
from the food that they're that they're ingesting.
So that can be a component also.
So making sure that you're helping with prebiotics
and probiotics to help gut health
can be important as well.
But make sure also from that caccia video
that you try to do some exercises
to stimulate muscle mass growth
because the concern with weight loss in cancer
is that the cancer is utilizing
as baking glucose from the protein at the muscle.
So the way to beat that is to have the muscle call
for its own need so that your body will say,
oh, well, we can't take this muscle mass
because she's using it and that could slow down
the cancer growth.
So doing some weights lifting,
to eat some exercises could be your best friend.
And I'm active.
I'm not one to sit around or anything.
Okay, good.
Active during the day.
You see after it's dinner though I kind of read.
The third question I had is about moles
that are not looking really well.
I was wondering what your thoughts are
about having them surgically removed cut out.
Is that going to produce circulating tumor cells?
Yeah, so I don't know if they're cancering on
but the risk is always there.
Yeah, I have a very strong opinion
about surgical removal of possible skin cancers.
I very much against it.
I mean, if you have a basal cell cancer
removing a basal cell cancer,
I don't see really any harm in that if it's,
but a basal cell cancer is pretty easy to identify.
It's typically kind of shiny and raised
and it looks like a flat raised surface
with a little bit of a sheen to it versus something
that is darker usually.
Yeah.
And looks more ominous.
That could be a squamous or a melanoma.
And if you remove that,
the way that is done at a dermatologist's office,
they're not going to just remove it.
They're going to do what's called a mose surgery.
So they'll cut around it.
Everything that they can get the visual edges
and they'll send it to the lab immediately
and say it has clean borders.
You know, it doesn't have clean borders.
If it doesn't, they go look deeper.
They keep going until there's clean borders.
You know that.
But I think that there's really,
there's a lot of dangers to that.
That is the fastest way to spread a melanoma.
You'd be much better off using either essential oils
on it to kill it.
I've had patients that use some different essential oils,
some oregano oil and fracon sense on it to kill it.
Otherwise, the treatment, if you really believe
that it's a possible melanoma,
the other treatment is black sav.
And we made a little video on black sav a few weeks ago,
Michelle and I in a members video.
We used black sav on numerous patients with melanomas
and it was the only way to go.
It can be very painful, but it's the way to go.
Yeah.
Yeah, right now, I'm putting out like this big plant.
Yep, that's another treatment for it too.
Yep.
Okay, all right.
That's all for now.
I've been looking at bromeline.
Are you familiar with bromeline from pineapples?
Yes, so that's an enzyme, yep.
For pain.
Yep, so yeah, you can use enzymes for pain.
Some people it helps, some people it doesn't.
That is another choice.
What's your pain level, but Ed?
Right now, the only pain level I,
the only pain I have is in my knees.
It started back in April and I've not been able to,
you know, it's been continually getting worse at times.
I want to expire factor to help some,
but I really think it's more in the nerve
than it is in the muscle.
And I've not found anything to really help.
And I'm not going to take Tylenol, so.
Right.
I just live with it.
Yeah, it's hard.
Did you be tried?
Things like hot and cold packs on it and tens unit.
That's another possible help for pain.
Yeah, yeah.
Obviously, the tens unit, and I've also used,
you know, hot and cold.
It only lasts for, you know, the tens unit only lasts
for a short time.
Yeah.
But that's family.
I'll make it through.
I am just blessed beyond the past three years
of being almost four years now.
Being diagnosed with cancer and really having no pain issues.
I hear everybody on here that, you know,
has the suffer with pain issues.
And my heart really just breaks for them.
And I think, you know, what I got to complain about,
I got, you know, to me that, you know, father me
when I walk, but I can move back.
The Lord's been very good to me.
Well, it always is the most beneficial if we just try to,
even though it's so difficult times just to count our blessings.
Yeah.
And try to just focus on what's good.
Even though it's hard to see that sometimes,
we're in a lot of pain or we're really struggling.
Right, right.
Well, thank you very much.
All right, any other questions?
I have one if nobody else does.
Go right ahead.
I guess on the subject of chemo brain.
And I just been thinking I've seen some commercials,
and then I've seen some Shark Tank episodes about supplements
that are, like, for focusing and help with memory
and, you know, just kind of help concentrate.
Is any of that legit?
Is there anything out there that really does work?
Yeah, there really is.
You know, we used to do years ago, I used to see a lot of
brain-based people.
Well, one of my degrees is in functional neurology.
So we used to see a lot of ADD, ADHD, Alzheimer's,
Parkinson's, dementia patients.
And the brain, due to the extremely beneficial,
there's a lot of about there.
We created one called our own mix.
I just, there wasn't one that had everything in it that I
want, that we call our brain anti-inflammatory mix.
That's called BAM, and it's a powder.
Similar to the mushroom powder, if anybody
takes that, but it's totally different ingredients.
And it's for brain inflammation.
There's, we have numerous products in our store for that.
Primary research.
My lab has a really good one.
I think it's called CeraVend.
That's what it is, C-E-R-E-V-E-Ed CeraVend.
That's for, like, an A-G as you A-G, you have memory loss.
But it's still the same herbs, whether it's chemo-brain or not.
So the standard process has some with individual components.
And those are like Bocopa.
Curcumin can help.
So anything that's going to help detoxify the brain and help
decrease inflammation of the brain is beneficial.
So yeah, those herbs can help.
It's always the source of the herb.
And people react differently to different herbs.
So if you purchase something, you try it.
And this isn't really helping.
Try something different because you will
let that something, wow, this really helps
it really clears my mind.
We have lots of patients that are taking ban.
And we have lots of patients that take the CeraVend that just
swear by it, too.
So those herbs do help.
And those would even help for, like, non-cancer patients?
Yeah, yeah.
They really were not made for cancer patients.
But it's for that just that memory loss, whether it just
make it if it's whether it's caused from the chemo or what
it's caused from glucose levels with diabetes or whether it's
caused from just degeneration from toxicity and early
Alzheimer's.
And what do young person have those issues?
Why would a young person have those issues?
Well, the biggest reason why young people
have any brain issues, ADD, ADHD, has to do with toxicity,
has to do with vaccinations that they
received, reactions to vaccinations, because they
have specific detox pathways where they don't get rid of those
hedgehogs and things from the vaccines,
the diet, chemicals, flavorings, additives,
colorings, gluten.
You have gluteal morphine receptors, and you're
got that fire directly to the brain.
Casine, which is the protein in dairy.
So you have casio morphine receptors that fire directly
to the brain.
So the first thing you do is young people with ADD, ADHD,
and issues with brain fog and can't concentrate.
They really have to get off gluten and most likely dairy.
Many times with those kids, we used to have to run lamb tests
so that you'd have a hard copy of showing their sensitivity
to gluten peptides so that they could go to school with this
and say, I can't be on this stuff.
And you can put them on some herbs that will help clean up
the brain as I discussed.
And you can see really dramatic results with those kids.
Dr. Quick, question on that.
On the green tea, do you not like the product?
My Q&L labs, Q&L labs.
The EGCG from them.
Again, honestly, I just see only what I trust.
I don't, I'm not familiar with that one.
That's Dr. Dr. Bob Marshalls.
Oh, Bob Marshalls.
But that would be the next best one, yes.
OK, that's the one I'm taking.
Dr. Connors.
Uh-huh.
I'm listening to various functional medical doctors
about that fasting, very intermittent fasting.
So there's like six different stages of fasting,
but it's over.
Anyway, it helps with the stem cells,
notes with etopathy, energy.
We set to DNA, turn the bed, jeans off,
and turn the good jeans on.
Uh-huh.
That's the microbiome you got.
And then the last one was growth hormones.
Good thing.
Is that something that you want to see happen with us
with the cancer?
Well, no, you don't.
So that's why it's important the way you fast.
That's why I stress on what all our cancer, other,
cancer fasting videos that, so if you're
going to do a straight water fast for 20, less than 24 hours,
so you're going to just water fast today, and then tomorrow,
you're going to eat again.
That's just fine for a cancer patient.
If you're going to do a straight water fast for more than a day,
so you're going to do a couple of day straight water fast,
that's not a good idea for cancer patients.
Is it a good idea for a non-cancer patient?
Well, as long as you don't have diabetes or something like that,
then yeah, you could fast for multiple days.
But the reason, the difference is that one component
that you mentioned, Deb, it's the IGF1.
The IGF1 levels will stay low if you do just a one day fast,
but if you stay out of fast, your IGF1 levels will go up,
which is desirable if you don't have cancer,
but is not desirable if you have cancer.
That's why we recommend either the intermittent fasting,
so you're not fasting more than a part of a day,
or the fasted mimicking diet.
So the fasted mimicking diet, you don't
have to worry about that at all.
And you're going to lower IGF1 levels.
You're going to lower that growth hormone factors.
You're going to lower M-tore, which is the replication piece.
And that's what's going to be best for cancer patients.
Is the fasted mimicking diet best for an athlete who's
trading for the Olympics?
No, maybe not.
Maybe doing a three-day fasted, going
on a more ketogenic diet is going to be best for them.
Yes, it is different with cancer patients,
and it has to do with the IGF1 levels.
So if you're fasting like the 14, 16 hours a day,
and two meals a day for us, for the cancer people.
You're fine, that's a good one.
Yep, you're really fine, that.
All right, just you said you considered
that a keto-like diet is totally in the keto genesis,
but it gives us some keto.
That's right, that's right.
So it's a lower age, your total glucose levels.
OK, and then we still want to monitor the glucose, correct?
That would be best, yes.
And keep it at level again?
Well, anywhere between 65 and 85 would be good.
OK, thank you.
And also, you were mentioning the lady before us.
She's something about calcium in your blood.
That has to do with bone cancer.
That does, yes, if you have high levels of calcium
that can be an indication of osteolytic activity,
be bold as being broken down?
She's, since my pharmacist there, should I be checking that?
That's something that should be done pretty regularly
by your doctor as just calcium levels.
Well, honestly, I'm just doctoring with you mostly.
OK, so what does a lot, what should you talk about your lab
instead?
OK, we had to get my D3 measures.
So I go this Monday to the traditional doctor and put
me traditional totally.
But I'm just going to say, yes, like a bubble head, yes, yes,
yes.
And then I have the test, the cyrix test coming into you.
OK.
Are you going next Monday, you said?
The 28, yeah.
OK, so then ask them to do blood calcium levels.
OK.
OK, probably be perfect.
All right, I have to let you go, where our time is up.
I will get this up unreported if you want to listen to it
again.
And I thank you all for joining.
And we'll see you next week.
Thank you.
Bye.